all right now that Colts explained why
we want to use a more traditional
object-oriented class-based setup let's
go ahead and do that now we'll be using
a piece of code by John Resig that fakes
class-based object-oriented programming
feel free to take a look at the code or
the linked blog below to see how it
works now we're not terribly interested
in the internals for our purposes what
we care about is how to use it for
instantiate the proper class-based
inheritance trees for our game objects
so let's say we want to create the
following inheritance tree we want
weapon and entity to both inherit from
class and we want machine gun and chain
gun to inherent from weapon and teleport
and energy cannister to inherit from
entity now we've started this off for
you but we're gonna have you complete
this yourself first we set weapon to be
class dot extend what this means is that
weapon extends all of classes
functionality whatever that happens to
be and then adds its own on top of it
similarly machine gun is set to weapon
dot extend which extends all of weapons
functionality and then builds on top of
that now we've created these for you for
a template and what I'd like you to do
is fill in the rest of the inheritance
tree we discussed above